IN IT COMES, DANGEROUSLY TO BAM.
2 1/2 MINUTES LEFT IN THE FIRST
HALF.
A ONE POINT LEAD FOR MIAMI.
A RUN THAT JUST ENDED, THANKS
TO JIMMY BUTLER, WHO GETS HIT
WITH A TECHNICAL FOUL.
>> John: YOU JUST CAN'T BE THAT
OVERLY  --
>> Eric: OH!
JIMMY BUTLER IS THROWN OUT OF
THE GAME.
JIMMY BUTLER GOT THE FIRST
TECHNICAL FROM MOUSA DAHGER.
THAT ENDS THE NIGHT FOR BUTLER
AFTER JUST 15 MINUTES.
SOMEBODY IS GOING TO HAVE TO
SHOOT THE FREE THROW FOR HIM.
>> John: THAT IS TOO QUICK ON
THAT SECOND TECHNICAL FOUL.
YOU'VE GOT TO LET THE PLAYER
COOL OFF AFTER THAT.
HE WENT AT THE FIRST OFFICIAL.
HE DESERVED THAT TECHNICAL,
RIGHT THERE.
HE DESERVES THAT TECHNICAL.
HE REALLY DOES.
BUT, HE WALKED AWAY THERE.
WHY IS HE PICKING UP THE SECOND
TECHNICAL AT THAT POINT?
HE IS WALKING AWAY TO THE FREE-
THROW LINE.
LET HIM CALM DOWN.
IF HE CONTINUES TO GO BACK AT
THAT OFFICIAL --
>> Eric: YOU ARE RIGHT ,
JOHNNY.
HE DESERVED THAT TECHNICAL.
>> John: THAT'S A BIG LOSS FOR
MIAMI.
JIMMY STRUGGLED A BIT HERE
EARLY, THAT'S WHY HE IS SO
EMOTIONAL ON THIS PLAY.
WHEN THEY DOUBLE-TEAM QUICKLY
ON THAT SECOND ONE, HE GETS
TOSSED.
NOW, SOMEONE IS GOING TO COME
IN FOR THE HEAT.
JIMMY IS NOT GOING TO BE ABLE
TO FINISH THE AND ONE PLAY
HERE.
THE BLAZERS GET TO PICK WHO
THEY WANT OFF THE BENCH TO
SHOOT THIS FREE THROW.
IT'S GOING TO BE CHRIS SILVA,
WHO IS NOT A GREAT PERCENTAGE